y
[Música]
el mundo registra más de 25 millones de
personas contagiadas con kobe 19 los son
recuperados llegan ya a los 16 millones
mientras que las víctimas superan los
800 44 mil pese a ser el séptimo país
con la mayor cantidad de casos de
contagio colombia puso en marcha el
desmonte de la cuarentena obligatoria y
el restablecimiento de la vida social y
comercial pero con restricciones tenemos
informe desde la ciudad de bogotá la
capital colombiana
una persona fallecida y varios heridos
deja una serie de manifestaciones y
enfrentamientos entre ciudadanos y la
policía en las ciudades de portland y
chicago en eeuu
esto ante el reinicio de las
manifestaciones ciudadanas contra el
abuso policial y el movimiento black
light matters
y también belarús un registro masivas
manifestaciones ciudadanas en rechazo a
los son resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales señaladas de fraude los
enfrentamientos con las fuerzas de
seguridad dejaron 130 personas detenidas
muy buenas noches bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 soy santiago lópez
gonzález gracias por estar con nosotros
hasta ahora aquí en france 24 lo
anunciamos en titulares en el mundo ya
hay más de 25 millones de personas
contagiadas con el coronavirus así lo da
a conocer el conteo que adelanta a la
universidad johns hopkins que también
indicó que este fin de semana la cifra
de fallecidos llegó a los 844 mil 118
personas mientras que la de recuperados
llegó a los 16 millones 486 mil 194
personas
eeuu es el país con más casos
confirmados y se acerca rápidamente a la
barrera de los 6 millones de casos
y mientras tanto colombia es el séptimo
país en el mundo con la mayor cantidad
de casos confirmados también es el
tercero en la región de américa latina
con 607 mil 938 casos confirmados en la
jornada de hoy
allí fue reactivada parte de la vida
social con la apertura de los parques y
de las ciclovías dominicales eso sí con
restricciones con el uso obligatorio del
tapabocas y guardando el distanciamiento
social esto después de cinco meses de 40
en obligatoria en ese país suramericano
que llevó a un confinamiento nacional
considerado uno de los más largos del
mundo en bogotá nuestra compañera andrea
maya nos cuenta cómo fue ese primer
domingo sin restricciones para los
colombianos y para los bogotanos
los habitantes de bogotá vuelven a salir
a las calles a hacer deporte gracias a
la reapertura de la ciclovía que estuvo
cerrada durante 5 meses todos los
domingos y festivos- bogotá pone a
disposición 127 kilómetros de esos
vídeos para que la gente tenga la
oportunidad de hacer ejercicio al aire
libre en este día de reapertura se vio
mucha gente pues a las 7 de la mañana
que es la hora inicial de la ciclovía ya
varias de las calles estaban
completamente llenas es una de las
oportunidades que hace que las personas
salgan se distraigan y que de cierta
manera como que no lo olvidemos pero sí
tengamos precaución frente pues a la
pandemia pues es realmente una buena
iniciativa por parte de la ciudad que
creo que la evidencia hoy por hoy
muestra que este tipo de actividades al
aire libre pues tiene muchísimo bajo
riesgo que otro tipo de actividades
entonces era importante que la gente
pudiera salir pudiera moverse que
pudiera tener un espacio diferente para
que para salud mental como también para
mejorar el sistema inmune
además de esto todos los 65 parques de
la ciudad los senderos ecológicos y los
gimnasios al aire libre también abrirán
de nuevo sus servicios a todos los
ciudadanos hace unos días de alcaldesa
de bogotá claudia lópez puso fin a todas
las cuarentenas obligatorias que se
estaban organizando en varios sectores
de la ciudad y le dijo a todos los
ciudadanos que a partir de ahora el
cuidado desde cada uno así que se
mantendrán las medidas como el uso
obligatorio de mascarilla también el
distanciamiento social y el buen lavado
de manos en otros temas el gobierno de
china anunció el envío a hong kong de
una comitiva para realizar pruebas de
kobe 19 gratuitas a la población una
decisión que ha sido calificada como un
boicot por parte de los sindicatos de la
salud que ven amenazada sus libertades
los planes de china para controlar la
pandemia hong kong encontraron
resistencia en un sindicato de
trabajadores de la salud pro demócratas
la alianza de empleados de la autoridad
hospitalaria hong kong está formada
durante las protestas contra beijing el
año pasado pidió sabotear el plan
universal de pruebas que adelantará el
gobierno chino desde el primero de
septiembre un proyecto que realiza en
cooperación con un equipo de 60
profesionales de la salud de china
continental para tratar de controlar la
pandemia hong kong el gobierno local
tiene un solo objetivo usar el control
del virus para hacer todo para complacer
al gobierno central de china incluso si
eso significa poner la política por
encima de todas las cosas el sindicato
integrado por unas 20.000 personas dijo
que las pruebas universales no son una
manera eficiente de invertir los
recursos ni de controlar el virus por lo
que se deben implementar pruebas
localizadas el activista pro demócrata
dario wong acompañó este llamado y
reiteró que sólo existe una salida para
detener la propagación del virus es hora
de darse cuenta cómo los gobiernos de
beijing y hong kong
virgen y facilitan la interferencia en
holcomb con la excusa del coi 19 cerrar
la frontera es la única salida la
desconfianza incrementa en hong kong
luego de que el gobierno chino
estableció una nueva ley de seguridad
nacional en junio para restringir la
libertad de expresión a los ojos de los
críticos pero terminó de consolidarse
luego de que beijing pospusiera un año
más las elecciones legislativas de
septiembre citando riesgos para la salud
pública por la pandemia
y de otra parte en portland en los eeuu
una persona falleció debido a un disparo
al parecer en los enfrentamientos entre
los seguidores del presidente de donald
trump y manifestantes del movimiento
black life matters otro tiroteo también
fue registrado en la ciudad de chicago
en illinois
la policía y los médicos rodearon el
cuerpo de una persona que murió a causa
de disparos la noche del sábado en la
ciudad de portland el tiroteo ocurrió la
misma noche en que estallaron violentos
enfrentamientos entre manifestantes de
blacklight smarter y simpatizantes del
presidente de eeuu donald trump que
recorrieron el centro de portland en
cientos de vehículos un portavoz de la
policía dijo que era demasiado pronto
para relacionar la muerte del individuo
con los enfrentamientos y ya me cansé de
ver a gente racista venir a esta ciudad
y hacerme sentir intimidado y difundir
sus mentiras con sus banderas me hace
sentir realmente disgustado quiero
protestas pacíficas y no puedo decirle a
la gente cómo protestar pero al mismo
tiempo entiendo por qué todos los que
están en contra de trump están
protestando esta noche porque todos
estamos frustrados y aquí estamos ahora
hay un cadáver en el suelo
el periódico the new york times- lo
identificó como un hombre blanco que
vestía un sombrero con la insignia de
patchwork rey de un grupo de extrema
derecha con sede en portland aunque la
policía no ha revelado los detalles de
la víctima ni de los sospechosos del
tiroteo varias personas fueron
arrestadas durante los violentos
enfrentamientos del sábado por la noche
horas después chicago fue el escenario
de otro tiroteo dos policías resultaron
heridos luego de que intentarán detener
a una persona sospechosa de llevar un
arma el sujeto disparó contra los
agentes y un tercer policía acudió a la
escena e hirió al sospechoso la
situación se da justo en una tensa
semana de nuevas protestas contra la
brutalidad policial y el racismo
avivadas por la muerte de jake & blake
un hombre negro que recibió siete
disparos en la espalda por parte de un
oficial el pasado domingo en la ciudad
de que no se en wisconsin y nuevamente
las calles de las principales ciudades
de belarús fueron escenario de
manifestaciones ciudadanas en rechazo a
los son resultados de las elecciones
presidenciales del pasado 9 de agosto
las protestas terminaron en
enfrentamientos con las autoridades y en
detenciones de unas 130
zonas
decenas de miles de opositores vio los
rusos marcharon contra alexander
lukashenko belarús registró otra jornada
histórica en la que se exigió en
libertad en el país y la dimisión del
presidente al que acusan de fraude en
las elecciones del 9 de agosto las
marchas en minsk llenaron las
principales calles de la capital aunque
la policía trató de impedir el avance de
la manifestación en algunos puntos vine
aquí para expresar mi desacuerdo con los
resultados de las elecciones por
supuesto expresar mi solidaridad con las
personas detenidas y los presos
políticos estoy a favor de la paz de
belarús pero no de lukachenko durante la
jornada la policía registró decenas de
detenciones algo que la oposición
denuncia y asegura que en el país hay
cientos de presos políticos a pesar de
las tres semanas de protestas y huelgas
en muchos sectores
lukashenko mantiene el poder y amenaza
con tener el apoyo de rusia en caso de
emergencia
de hecho vladimir putin llamó a su
homólogo bielorruso por su cumpleaños y
le invitó a moscú para dialogar algo que
no parecen temer desde la oposición este
llano pues venimos siempre ya no tenemos
miedo el miedo se ha ido hace
venimos a apoyar a nuestra gente si
nuestros hombres son detenidos entonces
las mujeres protestarán si comienzan a
detener a las mujeres más hombres
protestarán ahora protestaremos siempre
es inevitable luego de 26 años de poder
indiscutible de alexander lukashenko
belarús encara su crisis política más
fuerte con una oposición unida frente al
oficialismo que tiene la idea de
restaurar las elecciones libres en este
país
es todo por el momento las noticias de
france 24 siga con nuestra programación
feliz noche
[Música]